欢迎收听古爱,我是圣木工
本期节目由NordVPN赞助
9月开学季到了
孩子们开始频繁使用平板电脑查资料跟线上学习
家里的长辈常在LINE群组点击各种连结
在全家大小都高度依赖网络的时代
家庭的数位安全防护绝对是第一优先
大家熟悉的NordVPN已经升级成为全方位数位安全解决方案
一个APP就可以有效阻挡钓鱼诈骗网站
拦截恶意软体下载与恼人广告
为全家人的上网环境建立第一道防线
不论是防止小朋友在网络上误触危险连接
或是下载到隐藏病毒的档案
还是避免长辈不小心点进假冒的诈骗网页
NordVPN都可以从源头直接拦截威胁
此外在外连线公共WiFi时
全程加密连线更能够防止个资跟信用卡资讯外泄
让大人小孩上网都无后顾之忧
像我自己的话蛮喜欢使用NordVPN的跨区服务
所以有时候遇到锁区都可以轻松的解决
而且现在NordVPN不只支援手机平板跟电脑
也已经支援Smart TV跟Apple Vision Pro
一个账号最多可以同时使用于10台装置
不论是在家或是外出都能够灵活使用
下次要透过资讯栏的专属连结
norevpn.com slash gooye
或在结账的时候输入优惠码 gooye
立即享有期间限定优惠
购买两年方案加送4个月
并提供30天退款保证
不满意都可以随时取消零风险尝试
这个月还有台湾的特别活动
详细可以看我们的资讯栏
在那边听我给所有需要的朋友们
這禮拜是我第一次的商務旅行
也就是出差
以前從來都沒有出差過
有點緊張
緊張的並不是說出差的內容
因為對我來說就只是去看一個展
然後我有點擔心
在牧章那附近會不會什麼小都沒有
但我最近稍微研究了一下
我發現還是有一些東西
包含說像我住的飯店
它裡面有一個餐廳
然後它有松茸
我一直都想吃看看松茸到底是什麼東西
說不定吃過之後我自己不知道
但就看到它有松茸料理
特別把它寫出來
所以還是帶有一點點的期待
可是對於家裡的事情就會稍微的比較放不下心
雖然其實家裡有蠻多各種資源
只是在我昨天要離開前
就是跟我兒子稍微的講了一下
爸爸要出去四天
那你要好好聽媽媽的話
我四天之後就會回來
我會帶你喜歡的玩具回來之類的
他直接給我大爆哭
我大兒子直接大爆哭
你知道他現在已經進入一個
就是覺得自己很帥的年紀
小朋友大概在四五歲之後
特別如果家中有一個比較小的弟妹或是有朋友來的時候你會發現說他很常在耍帥我覺得他故意跳到沙發上面然後回頭看一下他的同學或是故意做一些他知道他弟弟不會做的動作
那時候在北海道的時候他就是
不停的示範給弟弟看怎麼樣從沙發上跳下來
弟弟就想學他嘛
弟弟又不會跳他怎麼樣
他直接給我原地往後倒
他想學他跳可是他不會
他就原地往後倒然後頭撞地板
他那個地板是木地板
但整個晚上我們兩夫妻都很緊張
看他有沒有在呼吸什麼的
因為怕說會不會撞到腦袋
要緊急送醫之類的
還好是沒事情
但是這麼愛耍帥的一個兒子
一直跟他告誡說你不要再這樣子
你的弟弟會學你
或是你的同學覺得這樣一點都不帥
可是當他知道我要離開的時候
就直接連眼都不眼就開始爆哭
開始細數我們的種種
平常下課可以跟爸爸幹嘛
晚上跟爸爸幹嘛要洗澡什麼的
下課沒有人接
晚上沒有人陪睡什麼的
就是開始念
接著就是告訴你說
他多爱你什么的
这个是一个非常神奇的体验
我觉得甚至有点到魔幻体验的感觉
所以还有这次的出差
才可以让我感受到这种
在人生之中没有感受过的体验
就是有一个生命
他是由衷的需要你
他真的爱你
而且他会告诉你他的爱
那你说可能在过往
你的另外一半
或是你的老婆
跟你的女朋友
可能也给你过类似的体验
对 没错
但是那个体验
其实跟孩子是种很纯的爱
也是不太一樣的
我覺得當然
另外一半
當你今天可能要像有些聽眾講的
分隔兩地、遠距離
可能要出差很長期之類的
還是怎麼樣的
可能對方會有那種滿滿的思念
可是這種思念
很多時候最後都會變成是一種
就是嫉妒
然後外加控制魚
就是他可能會打個電話說
來你給我看一下你家旁邊有誰
以前我可能出去的時候
我就必須要把電話打起來
然後給我老婆看一下周圍有誰
要大檢查一下
再來就是可能會叫三餐茶琴
一開始可能是蠻甜的
你現在在幹嘛
你待會要幹嘛
可是等到第二天第三天
有些人可能非常享受這個過程
可是我就覺得說怎樣
你媽監控我
你到底問夠沒有
我就已經告訴你我要幹嘛
你還要再問
所以也有可能我是白目老
但我就不太喜歡那一種
他雖然是想你跟思念你
可是他的做法是一種
充滿控制慾的那種感覺
也不是說他不好
就是說相較之下
你就會知道孩子的這一種
就是純純的愛
他只希望你趕快回來
而且甚至是當你剛剛講說我會帶你最喜歡的寶可夢你最愛吃的糖果回來他直接說他不要寶可夢他不要糖果他就是要你這個是蠻奇幻的一種體驗
所以後來就慢慢的會懂得一些
我還蠻喜歡看
可能是什麼好萊塢的藝人
或是一些不知道
Tech Bros之類的
然後當我們去講他們家庭的事情的時候
你會注意到
雖然我們可能在不同的跑道
在不同的國家
可是面對自己的下一代
跟自己的孩子感受都是很像的
也都不約而同的非常享受那一段
看似是超級混亂
家裡可能會弄得亂七八糟
雖然已經有錢人打掃
但還是整天弄得亂七八糟
然後可能滿地都是玩具
有時候會讓你生氣
會讓你理智線斷掉
你必須要跑到隔壁的房間
去稍微的冷靜一下
那或是可能有時候
他很黏你的時候
一開始很高興
後面會覺得好煩喔
爸爸要工作
我可以不要一直這樣黏著我嗎
但是當他睡著的時候
我覺得特別就是孩子睡著的時候
去想這一段
就會覺得
你不知道你會突然發現
你的生命是有價值的
以前可能不覺得自己生命有價值
我就是一個無情的賺錢機器
我就是無情的工作機器
我就是要往上爬或什麼的
到時候你也不知道自己努力的東西是什麼了
可是當你感受到這一種很純的愛
我甚至會覺得這個愛是比
不知道人家講說刻骨鳴心的一段感情
对于老婆女朋友男朋友什么的
可是后来会发现说
最蠢最猛的爱真的是对于孩子
然后在像这种偶尔的小事件
因为我真的没有想过说
我跟我小朋友说我要出去四天
会获得这样的反应
这个是想都没有想过的事情
所以是觉得大家蛮高兴的
前几天又跑去抽携
这一段时间都会去定期的追踪
然后就超级意外的发现
哇这个每个数值都很漂亮
雖然自從開始密集的上網球功能訓練
還有那時候泰拳
就是已經很明顯的感覺到身體的改善
但直到體重掉下來之前
你是沒有感受到那種翻天覆地的一個味道
那到現在就是
不然說血壓就壓低
心臟跳的速度變滿慢的
各項指標都很好
即便在過去
其實我經歷了一個非常瘋狂的紅酒探險之旅
我現在已經開始踩煞車了
因為我已經算走完了
就是已經進入那種比較外圍
比較廣
跟有事沒事可以試看看這樣
所以就不會像之前
因為是一種想要去體驗跟感受大家講的東西到底是什麼所以就做到很極端就是媽整天在那邊喝之類的然後現在已經沒有了可是本來就有點緊張因為這樣子搞自己的身體幾個月不知道會發生什麼事情
結果一側什麼都沒有
真的完全都沒有
肝也沒有什麼事情
膽固醇也沒有什麼事情
什麼三酸甘油脂
什麼都是還OK的
所以就是有嚇到
我看來運動真的對自己的身體
有非常巨大的幫助
最近在功能訓練
又開始玩到一些新的東西
其實我覺得我教練真的是一個非常狂的人
他是那種會自己不停的去添購設備
除了自己瘋狂的去上課之外
他發現有一些新的設備就會把它找來玩
然後他最近搞了一個
我覺得比保加利亞帶更靠北的東西
他就是一個滑輪組
然後這個滑輪他可以固定在
不知道就那種史密斯架之類的
或是任何就是夠穩的
那種鐵柱上都OK
固定上去之後
他是一個滑輪跟一個把手
他的做法有點像是說
要去拉發動機
地板上有一個發動機
你手拉了把手
一隻腳就站穩
稍微有一點內拔
前腳稍微有一點內拔
因為這樣才可以發力
就像說你要抗阻地板
你要把地板吐出去那種感覺
才站得穩
後腳就是往後拉
正常的稍微微蹲
接著就開始去抽動發動機
你抽越大力
滾輪滾回去的力量就會越大
滾回去的時候
你就必須要把身體的重心下壓
用你的大腿跟屁股把力道給吃掉
接著你再拉下一發
這個東西變態在是怎樣
就是一般的健身的設備
我們知道說我們可以選定一個重量
如果說你想把同一個重量變得更加的
有挑戰性或是有難度的話
你可以稍微做慢一點
動作紮實一點或什麼
可是你已經知道說上緣大概在哪
是長什麼樣子
這個東西變態在
你只要用生命的力量去拉
他就會用生命的力量回饋你
當你把繩子全部抽出來之後
他捲回去的力量也會超級大
所以這時候你就會感覺到
你的屁股跟你的腿整個快爆開快炸開
這個是第一個運動
我做完我覺得我媽血糖偏低我要倒下來
真的就是這種感受
然後回去屌吃一頓
我現在還有在打到某件的
雖然我的體重已經沒有在掉
醫生就說反正就繼續打下去
就看怎麼樣
你也不要隨便停樣
因為不小心會負胖之類的
但其實體重已經很久沒有掉
食量也穩定
所以就整個人進入一個非常穩定的階段
你也不確定你去打這個藥目的是什麼
因為已經沒有什麼
被控制住的感覺
但自從去做這個運動之後
你回去食量又再一次的屌增
可是你的身體的體重
並沒有因為這樣增加
雖然那還很短期
可是感受下來就是
那個東西真的太耗能 太費力了
所以你的身體會告訴你說
等一下給我趕快去補充一些什麼
蛋白質 澱粉
你想吃什麼就用力的去吃
這個是很酷的一個體驗
就是我還蠻震驚
功能性訓練
但我後來就明白了
也不是說每個人的功能性訓練都可以玩得很複雜
那是因為我這個教練他是瘋狂的去進修
然後跟人去搞一堆設備
所以我覺得他是一個很有熱情的人
因為這樣子他的訓練就變得蠻好玩的
我蠻驚訝已經差不多三個月了
可是一點那種倦怠感都沒有
老實講像什麼泰拳以及網球
都有冒出過倦怠感
一個就是說 泰拳真的超級累
所以有時候想說還是有下次偷懶好了
網球的部分是太曬了
夏天真的太曬了
是曬到你會生氣
你想說我搬來林口是為了下雨跟霧
結果林口媽的狂出太陽
是出到你會很火大那一種
然後又很曬
所以就很受不了
但是功能訓練
因為最近自己也有家人跑去
開始在那邊練
然後就說你會不會覺得超累
那種很崩潰
然後跟下一堂課故意遲到5分鐘之類
希望可以少上一點
我說一開始真的超累
可是後來因為你看到有很多變化
然後跟你會注意到身體的一些很明顯的改變
其實有蠻多聽眾
因為我分享的時候就會去找我的教練
我教練自己是很滿
但是因為他很專業
就可以推薦各地的教練給大家
然後蠻多人的身體就應該這樣改善
我覺得是一個很棒的東西
就是他一開始有一個近摩差力
你要去克服
克服之後
因為他訓練了多元性的原因
所以就不會覺得無聊
你就一直想要去考
然後有很多的挑戰想要一一的把它去弄掉
我覺得也是一個蠻神奇的體驗
所以稍微跟大家分享一下
大概這樣
好那接下來我們就要來進入上昂的話題
那現在的盤面還是維持一個低波動的局面
這個盤感覺是已經像是死掉一半不太會懂了
但在今天以後說不定會有一些轉機
為什麼
因為超多人跑去抽漢測
就像那時候超多人跑去抽那檔7769是不是
但這次的規模好像比那次大很多
然後就有身邊的朋友去回撤當市場上有一堆人要去抽籤的時候因為那個錢要先被圈起來雖然感覺也不是什麼大錢但是一堆人的錢都被圈在那相當程度還是會影響到
整個市場的一些變化之類
所以用這樣去跑了一個回車就是說
當時那個錢放出來
市場就有活水的感覺
所以我們期待一下
在今天以後的市場看
會不會真的有這樣的一回事
產生活水
雖然我自己是打一個問號
因為你看國際盤也是屬於一個
像美國的NASDAQ
他感覺要跑到盤整下緣去
又感覺要出事了
感覺不會出大事
就只是又往弱勢的方向去
所以即便台灣這邊的活水出來也不一定
還是要看一下全球的盤面怎麼樣去跑
接下來我們來聊一下這間市場上最大的一個話題
就是在上禮拜六
Anthropic的Dario Almodi
發了一個3800字的文章
標題叫做We must pay the frontier
禮拜一直接把廢辦踹掉6%
自然股逆势喷了13%
到台股這邊
開盤就先嚇傻
接著是有拉回來
可是在禮拜二盤面
也都是維持一個比較不好
比較偏網絡的方向去走
Nasdaq又再次的
岌岌可危跑到下源
所以又一次
Dario又發了一個
我自己好強大
我好害怕
請大家來監管我的文章
但這次跟過去一個很大的差別
是他獲得了
OpenAI的Sam Altman
以及Tesla或是說XAI
或是說SpaceX的馬斯克的副意
我個人是覺得
先講我自己的看法
首先這三個人的關係
是有一點點不斷理還亂
我認為是互相賭攬的情形
但三個人竟然第一次站在同一個陣線
馬斯克其實自從Anthropic
去跟他租Data Center之後
他就改口了
其實馬斯克也是一個很典型的生意人
在Anthropic去跟他租借大家Center 之前
大家去爬他X的文
他對Dario是沒有好生好奇的
他也是跟我們一樣
就是很堵攔他整天去講這種幹文之類的
以及他也是
即便他主張
AI確實有可能會變成像Terminator
這樣是有點危險的
可是他對Anthropic也是有很多的批評
但自從變成是客人之後
這個講話就直接扭轉了180度
但馬斯克在我們的認知裡面
是比較屬於
他是崇尚自由經濟
他是崇尚政府不要管太多的類型
但在這件事情上面他站在Modi Dario我每次不知道他姓跟名我都很常搞反感可能是因為我對這個人真的非常反感就是說他的名字記不懂我很常用他的產品
不然說像我自己用的一些interface
後面就串模型
我都會刻意去選anthropic
可是我真的覺得這個人
我不知道
我覺得他超級猥瑣
那我自己的雷達我覺得蠻準的
就是過去覺得很猥瑣的人
像不然之前覺得SBF
然後後來發現那個Panihabity
就是你覺得他猥瑣
後面他就真的會出一些事情
因為我覺得是這樣子
就是有一些那種最基礎的直覺
我不知道去訓説什麼
我會看人什麼
沒有就是當你發現說
人群中的一些人
他的一些作為
就是很常會給你一種
很不協調的感覺
先不管他的產品做得多好
或是你多喜歡用他的東西
就是覺得這個人不太協調
就是怪怪的
我就覺得這個人
這真的是很奇怪
可是因為我自己算是
還蠻喜歡馬斯克
所以當馬斯克選擇
跟他站在同一個陣線的時候
我自己就有嚇到說
竟然會去複裔這樣的一個說法
再來 OpenAI這邊的Sam Altman
也是主張認為
在今年可能沒有辦法讓OpenAI上市
因為它有一些安全性的問題要去處理
難得大家在同一個陣線
這邊可以稍微插一個題外話
就是OpenAI拉到後面去上市
其實我覺得是好事情
如果說OpenAI跟Amphrapid在差不多的時間
然後發了S1然後上市
可能AI的故事就會提早結束
因為它就再也不是朦朧沒了
所有東西都看得到
所以我覺得那種題材的想像性
就會差很多
所以OpenAI拉到後面
應該算是一個好事情
不管它的理由是怎麼樣
但反正星星已經連呈現了
這個是天有意象
他們的看法竟然是一樣的
到底他們要的東西是什麼
會發生什麼事情
我們就直接用非常簡短的方式
跟大家說明自己的一些看法
因為基本上你在各大新聞
都可以找到他們的一些說法
簡單來說
他們希望在前文模型這邊
要有更多的一些管制
它并不是要去减慢训练或是推理
而是能力提升的速率
在某种共识之下
大家可以一起去刹车
有蛮多前提的
包含说中国这边
因为他知道他不一定会去
符合西方的一些要求
所以如果中国不愿意的话
那当然我们是不会去乱坐刹车
就是在大家有共识的状况之下
我们可以somehow去减速
所以一样就是那种超文青的文章
其实看了他超地堵然
但我們還是要去研究一下
他到底說什麼東西他覺得要有常駐的第三方評估者那是Amphlopi字局會選擇他引了一個機構進來雖然最近在ag上面開始被人家發說這個機構有一些離職的anthropy員工跑進去
然後再來這個機構的original funding
其實跟anthropy有蠻大的一個關係
也就是說他自己可能是求援兼裁判
然後這先不聊
我們等到真相出來再去做更深入的一個剖析
反正總之就是大家知道說
他想找一個類似那種公正的第三方
某種fact check
以及那種事實查案之類的
进入到每个公司里面
去帮大家看
看说你现在的模型
有没有合规
有没有对齐
有没有跟人类的目标跟意志
是在同一条线上的
就是你不会去脱缰恶搞之类的
然后再来民主国家的实验室
要去协调一些checkpoints
就是看大家的能力目前到哪里
你要有相对应的一些能力
才可以做相对应的一些发展
也就是不希望说
小孩开大车的仪式
然后再跟中国去谈
把这个协议给收窄
看中国可以配得到什么
我们就跟着去做
简单来讲
就是再次的他认为
因为AI太强大了
我好强大
我也好怕我自己
所以邀请政府来监管
那这边我蛮喜欢
美国副总统JD
他所讲的一个东西
就是在一个访问里面
然后他提到说
就是很奇怪
这些frontier labs
竟然每一个都自己要跑去
要跑去找這些官方
希望來做監管
他感覺有點像是Trojan Horse
其實如果我們今天去縱觀過往的歷史
就會知道
這些監管捕獲
他是從英文翻過來的字
也就是說
一些在業界的領先者
為什麼要去要求監管
因為他可以去設定一些遊戲規則
在要求監管的當下
他把遊戲規則
去往自己想要的方向做調整
他們的目的是什麼
监管本身会提高很多的作业成本
今天对于这些巨头或是领跑者来说
提高作业成本
就是可能毛利掉一点
但是对于新进的竞争者来说
他们可能为了要去符合
这些作业成本跟规范
还有要求以及监管
他有可能就跑不起来了
所以先讲一个
可能在这个节骨眼
我认为是偏向阴谋论的东西
我觉得他们并不是真的
为了人类的文明
或是為了大家好
所以要求要監管
他們在做的事情是
想要去把後面的一些競爭者給排擠掉
特別是我認為
Amphlopic跟OpenAI
他們在打的算盤是這個
當然今天他們可以去設定
監管的單位是誰
裡面安插自己人
他可以去lobby這些政治人物
然後要求往他要的方向去做
我也是跟他玩同一個遊戲規則
但是規則是我設計的
我知道怎麼樣去做
怎麼樣去繞
而且我已經有相當程度的基礎了
他們可以跟後面的競爭者拉開距離
甚至有些競爭者會連Full都Full不出來
他根本就沒有辦法去符合這些規章
所以他就可以把他的對手給擠掉
在TESLA或是SpaceX或是XAI的
馬斯克這邊
我覺得他打的算盤是另外一個
先講我是很喜歡馬斯克這個人
但是我們也知道說一個人他絕對不是玩人
我們也不是那種謎弟
他說講的東西都一定是對的
我們也會去講說
不然說他很常雷聲大雨點小
或是有些東西會髮夾彎之類的
但我算可以理解
聰明人蠻多都是這樣子
我自己也不是什麼特別聰明的人
我也很常懂那種一個感受
一個靈感
突然間我的方向就改變
可以懂這種隨機應變
他本來就是生存很重要的一個
怎麼講 技能
但是馬斯克他其實蠻多的盤算
就像跟他前面所聊到的
自從Anthropic 住戴亞Center之後
然後他對這家公司就開始
一面倒的美顏
大家可以去看那個分際點
超級明顯的
我覺得他要的東西
跟前面兩家不太一樣
因為他不太擔心後面的人追他
至少在這個階段
他是屬於在追別人的那一位
他要的是什麼
因為他現在要去搞超級大的Data Center
在美國之邊
以及他要去搞太空運轉
馬斯克一個非常強大的優點
就是他有很厲害的執行力
這個也是Janson講到
他說別人可能要花4年
才可以把同等規模的Data Center給弄起來
光是去建置把東西搞好就要3年
接著要讓他可以run要再1年
所以要4年
可是馬斯克只花了10幾天
當然這有點誇事
可是它速度真的超級快
它在很短的時間內就搞出了超大
那種Colossus的GPU Cluster
很大的一個訓練能量
因為它在後面追
而且其實前面XAI有一點算是踩錯方向
這個也算是某種程度的共識了
所以如果你們慢下來
對我就剛剛好
等到我把我的算力建置好
太空算力或是地面上的那種超級巨型的算力
到時候可能就可以直接實現彎道超車所以我會覺得他們是各懷鬼胎前面兩個會去要求監管他們就是監管捕獲反正他不希望有競爭者在後面
可以很輕鬆的挑戰他
在馬斯克這邊是偏向
你們最好就煞車一下
這樣子我就有機會在後面會追上
但這個比較偏向是我剛才沒講
他是那種陰謀論
我們要先去了解
每個人講話一定有他的動機
就像是你每次只要看到
看到Bill Ackman
就Pershine Square的
他跑出來跟你講某一個主題
然後講得很恐怖之類
你就知道他手上有部位
這已經驗證過太多次了
所以我算是先用這個方式去拆解
就是會覺得這些大老闆他們講這些東西
他們絕對不是只是為了人文關懷
然後甚至是其實我們如果去看過往發生什麼事情
OpenAI之前有一個超級對齊team
然後那個直接翻譯過來
簡單來講就是說他們內部去搞一個team
然後本來Promise要給20%的一個預算
裡面那個領頭之一就是伊利亞
Suskiver就是後來出去
公鬥被搞出去的那一位
結果最後面是怎麼樣
就是這個20%的Promise
預算要去做AI安全性的
只有一兩%的錢被丟進去
在一些訪問有被披露出來
並且給他們用的是最舊的晶片
這個其實很好理解
這個就很類似說
像我們之前在討論一些公司治理上面
為什麼台灣公司可能會覺得
一些像是資安或者說內控
或是有的沒有的相關的軟體跟支出
他們會不會不願意去花
因為跟業務沒有直接關係
就是老闆他很願意去花
在業務這邊可以直接看到收益的東西
可是安全性管控這類的
你只有等到你真的被駭客到了
真的出事情了
然後之後才開始注意
在那之前誰會想多花錢在這個地方
所以我也算是可以理解OpenAI
也不會想笑他們是偽君子
雖然是有一點像
但是你看你前面Promise的20%預算
最後面給這麼少
然後整個Team不見
然後後來出事情
就是那個Hugging Face事件
當個月就直接把那個
Preparedness團隊給解散掉
OpenAI是講說不是
這個是因為為了後面
可能上市的規劃
所以去做一些調整
無論如何
我就是認為說
就是大家一起在演一場戲
但這個東西他還是必須要把它講出來
為什麼 因為總是要卸責
如果說後面真的出事情
你看OpenAI的東西
跑出沙盒去那邊亂他總是要告訴大家說我已經有去做相對應的管控他其實有很多面向的切入一個面向就是卸責
再來就是說他可能有些陰謀論
像前面所提到的
他為了要去把一些對手給擠掉
再來也是有一個可能性
加在市場上一些反向的人
對AI比較看空的人
就有說Michael Burry他說這個是
為了去掩蓋成長放緩
為什麼 因為當然今天我要求說
我們在前面的回歸訓練RL
稍微的放慢一點
大家不要衝這麼快
我是不是就可以去justify
我可能在後面的一些硬體採購計畫
會去改變這個
這個是那種反方論述的人
可能會往這個方向去想
但這邊我先跟大家講一個大結論
在我們去拆解完這些
心理相關的東西之後
我是認為說在後面反而
可能會有一段時間
會出現整個論述的逆轉
因為我們剛剛前面講的
大家會認為說它像是一個利空
對不對
我們開始要去降速
我們要去做監管
要更加確認安全性
好像說整個速度會慢下來
但同時
因為現在你要去管控跟教育的東西是AI
你沒有辦法用人類去教育AI
你還是會用到大量的AI去教育這些AI
所以它代表的意思是什麼
如果說我們今天把AI模型的算力
訓練 驗證跟監控
把它稍微的具象化講出來的話
首先你要有訓練資料加RL的一個練習環境
接著你現在開始會有一個新增的東西
以前你把資料準備好之後
你就進入pre-trained RL訓練
就開始類似說讓這個模型讀書變聰明
但現在你必須要先去消毒
你必須先去過濾這些壞掉的題目
這部分就是新的算力的需求
因為你要去檢查這些東西
接著進入候選模型
Checkpoint的一個階段
這個時候就是變成
開始要去送考了
當這個東西已經是預訓練完成之後
你必須要
首先常駐第三方的評估者
會用公司的算力再去
考一次AI
然後確定他是可以run的
並且他們可以去獨立發表這個結果
如果獨立發表這個結果
我持一個保留意見
或是我覺得有可能問題的話
又可能要再多跑幾次
再來可能會有一個危險能力的測試
要確保說不會像之前一樣
逃出他的sandbox
跑去害別人
或者說還是說他終於產生生命力之類的這是一個那種常任務他可能會需要數個小時去跑也會用到很多的算力再來對齊考試因為AI它像前面所提到他可能會騙你
所以偶爾才作弊
不是每次在作弊
這時候怎麼辦
你就重新考他1000次
你就可以抓到他會不會作弊
所以又是新的算力的使用的用法
以及可解釋性的掃描
你會去打開他的腦袋去檢查
像模型的FMRI
看它的动机是不是正确的
又是新一波的算力要去使用
然后接着你deploy出去之后
模型推理一步一步的执行
你还得去监考AI
看它有没有想要跃拳攻击
或是说跑题跑掉
因为跑题跑掉代表有可能会有危险
接着你还必须要在可能有状况
或是说有一些疑虑出来的时候
再次的沙香隔离 sandbox
记录它
然后确保它没有问题
再给它多跑个几次
回報之後還可能要重考
或是你要把訓練的東西重新去修正過
我是沒有辦法找到例證說
我想得到的這幾個案例
加起來他會用掉多少算力
但這時候一樣
我就透過
因為現在每個人都要用AI
我也一直用AI
我請他去調一下過往的資料
他就有發現
過往像比如說
OpenAI曾經試圖用20%的力量
去做超級對齊
就類似這樣去做一個推論
你可能你的步驟多這麼多
你可能需要花掉15%到20%以上
所以他是要用到更多的算力的
即便說他可能用了不久
就是最新Cloudstrike所推出的一些方案
他說其實我們不用用最尖端的東西
可以把治安做好
說不定會跟這些治安公司去做一些合作
所以你看到人家股價跑去噴
之前甚至是在幾個月前說什麼
Methos要把治安殺掉
那時候我們一直跑出來diss一下
吐槽說是覺得這個太奇怪
怎麼會有這樣的一個說法
這次也是有一點類似是逆風
就稍微的講一下
其實說不定後面一段時間
大家會突然意識到這件事情
就是你要讓它去做到驗證跟監控
它其實隱含的是
你要用掉更多的算力
所以它一部分是減緩
就是說大家一起慢下來
雖然我覺得這是一個賽局
大家不太可能會慢下來
但假設真的Reach Mozo Consensus
可以稍微的減緩一點
但是其實我們知道一下它最卡的
在AI用掉最後算力的
是在推論那一塊
所以訓練可能掉一點點
然後推論一樣多
而且甚至會更多
然后外加你现在还要有更多新的推论
要用在验证跟监控上面
所以理论上算力的使用会用到更多
所以我会觉得像礼拜一你说废半叠
然后硬体叠
這個是蠻奇怪的
在我的觀點會覺得是蠻奇怪的
所以稍微用自己的方法記錄給大家看
前面先猜心理的部分
他們為什麼要這樣子講話
我還是覺得很北蘭奇怪
現在我覺得連馬斯克的東西
都要稍微的挺一下
因為他是為了自己的利益在說話
每個人一定都是為了利益在說話
只是如果做到那種連也都不演的話
就是要評估一下
反而我現在覺得像是David Sachs
或甚至川普這種超白目超直接的
就是我只要有一個超高IQ的領導者
你們根本不用擔心AI有沒有衝就對了
我覺得都比那些偽君子更動聽
就是他們的說法太噁爛了
你也很簡單就可以去驗證
你各位下要把你的AI打開
然後去看一下這幾個人
然後再過去的AI預測
他們已經講了好幾年了
那就都miss
不然說像老黃會舉的那個例子
放射科的醫師
說以後就不需要這麼多放射科醫師
因為AI會看
結果沒想到需求反而是爆發
所以人對未來的預測是很不準的
既然你是這麼不準的話
你們想要講這些東西到底又是在幹嘛
從幾年前就說
AI要讓大家怎麼樣死
大家都沒有死
最終都發現說
大家都在為自己的利益說話
所以乾脆直接去看
這件事情對他們有利的東西在哪
我就會發現說這個事情會看得蠻清楚的
再來就是
像市場上的共識
是可能在硬體這邊會減緩或是停掉
我不覺得
我覺得可能在Sentiment這邊會受到影響
P Ratio搞不好要再下求一些是OK
可是在實質的用量上
如果真的要這樣子搞的話
他只會用到更多
這就是我的一些簡短的看法
這邊稍微的分享給大家參考看看
好接下來我們進入Q的部分
還有一隻也這樣狂漲連跌
其實就是時不時都會有這樣子的標的
那一般有看到打星星的
就是告訴你說他曾經有分割過
不管他是割集
他就會有一個註記在上面
那知不知道 當然知道
只是像我們的節目
一般就不會去聊這些比較小型的標的
甚至我在台股的標的
天地良心
大家就從以前到現在應該都知道說
我是不太去Cue一些中小的
即便我自己做很多中小
那都還是以產業的大趨勢為主
所以我們是不太可能會去
針對單一標的去聊那你說知不知道一定都知道市場裡面的各種鬼怪各種飛天遁地的東西突然間暴漲突然間暴跌我們一定都會去了解一下到底是發生什麼事情
如果說自己也算可以掌握的話
就會一起蹭車
再來講說會不會去參加抽籤
我自己是不參加抽籤
因為我一向都認為說
第一個生活已經過得蠻不錯
第二個千運沒那麼好
綜合第一個就是
你就覺得說自己的生活還算可以
所以如果又再有一堆這種去刷好運的東西
那會不會不小心把自己的運賠掉
這是我自己的一些感受
甚至有時候我自己在手遊抽卡的時候
然後一直不停的臉黑
我都會覺得說
這個等於是在把我日常的不好的運抽掉
所以我是沒有那種抽獎運的
因為早期會去稍微跟單抽獎一下
那現在都不去做了
你說這個抽籤要不要抽
其實理論上如果說你有閒錢的話
最好都去抽一抽
那個抽到也是蠻爽的
那我不用小孩抽也不會
那下面一位
Ray 嗨嗨梦公
你是我跟老婆的老公
一 老婆对目前生二胎很犹豫
她不喜欢带娃
但又喜欢小孩
如果是你要第三个会怎么考虑
二 有帮孩子买医疗保险吗
三 平时研究是否会关注大陆A股
半年前江海被点了就喷了几根
最后希望梦公祝老婆LAP品
9月22号生日快乐
并给四个字祝福
恭喜发财
没梗的 只为这一个
首先如果说不喜欢带小孩
但是又喜欢小孩怎么办
就找别人带小孩
这时候可能老公老婆协调一下
看谁去赚钱
这两个都在赚就认真赚
然后接着就去请一个保姆到家里
不管是半天的或是说全日的
那一般全日的就会很贵
但相对的它就可以去缓解掉很多
带儿的各式各样的痛苦
我们自己目前也只有请保姆
所以如果真的觉得带小孩很累的话
就是请一个保姆
但是還是要了解到的是
當你升到第二胎
甚至是到第三胎
首先我覺得從第一胎變第二胎
你的生活難度並不是變兩倍
其實變三到五倍
因為他們兩個會輪流發瘋之類的
所以特別是你要出國之類的
那壓力又更大
我覺得你要有心理準備
也不是說什麼你找人就可以解決
因為很多事情是找人也沒有辦法解決的
因為小朋友就是要找你
他就是不想要跟阿姨
不想要跟保姆
他只要跟你
再來講說有沒有去買醫療保險
其實我本身是不太會去買各式各樣保險
但是我目前我的孩子有買醫療錢
為什麼
因為剛好認識銀行的行員
幫人家做個業績
再來會不會去關注大陸A股
其實近年已經比較沒有看了大概在2019 18以前還會去做一些入股然後現在比較沒有了他們的指數也沒做現在還會做一些什麼護身正二之類現在都不會看
因為覺得中國市場
是沒有那麼好的一個環境
那再講說什麼
江海被我點了就噴了幾根
沒有啦
因為那時候就是抓到了
被動元件的漲價
那一波真的很大
上半年漲最多的就是被動元件
當然現在其實蠻多都軟屌
都在休息
但漲價的趨勢都還是在持續
那也不是說我們點了就噴
因為我們畢竟是在
雖然沒有在產業界裡面
但是我們認識很多產業界的人
所以我們會有一些風聲
都會立刻知道
所以有時候就會有這樣子意外的一些發展
但是也不要把這邊當成是爆牌台
就是你可能聽到某些東西立刻跑去買
有時候會被套到
然後被套到又回來那邊幹幹交
所以這樣當然是
一種產業分析的渠道
如果說對你有幫助那是最好的
只是自己要怎麼樣應用
自己要去稍微的思考一下
下面一位 翟克瑞王
孟公主角您好
之前留言被念叨后
顺利的get药厂的offer
这段期间我的朋友阿摩
也帮了我很多履历跟面试方面的问题
9月19号车生日
可以拜托孟公用猛男的声音
帮我跟他说那四个字吗
你屌好大
下面一位
亲爱的挨大
可以跟我说生日快乐吗
生日快乐
那谢谢
祝何家平安喜乐
另外两个问题
一对于散户来说
厂上是不是真的没有3%以下的资金了
二
申请高资产客户对散户来说
會利大於弊嗎
最近被喜說禮遇很多
可以申請困惑中
感謝主委開示
第一個
對就是如果現在要拿到3%以下的
以股票的資金來說是蠻難的
房子的話還是有辦法
股票的話就我理解下載蠻困難
信貸的話因為我比較不熟悉
所以沒有辦法評論
再來說高資產客戶
這是不是在講說什麼專業投資人
就是你有3000萬
然後就可以去綁一個專業投資人
還是看人
就如果說你懂得用的
那開啟一些特別的權限特殊的渠道
確實是會很好用
但是我自己知道蠻多菜籃族
他們去開了這些之後
然後就是被壞壞理專
強調不是每個理專都這樣
就壞壞理專壞壞的營業員什麼的
然後就推他們一些很奇怪的產品
然後接著就是套到深處無願有
所以這個是自己要研究的
就是說你開啟了一扇大門
可是這個大門會出來的
你不確定是鬼還是神
這都是自己要好好的評估一下
下面一位
Yu Ting Chang
嗨 孟公主家 我是比你年輕的氣氛仔
自從聽了你的育兒日記之後
每次跟朋友聊到生活大小事
我都能夠用你的育兒思維來解釋跟分享雖然朋友們都不是聽眾但你在節目中分享的日常點滴真的带给我很多面对生活与处理事情的启发9月19号是我的生日原本有跟男友许愿希望听到梦公祝我生日快乐
但想想还是靠自己投稿最实在
想起梦公用巴斯光年的声音跟我说声
生日快乐 她口
我不会学巴斯光年
不是啊 这个男友怎么当的
当到你的女朋友直接决定放弃你自己来
但也蛮厉害的 直接一次就成功
祝你生日快乐 下面一位
阿丸平时对朋友女友很好
却发现她创业与我同性质
封锁我加上抄袭长达半年
期间还接受我的好意赠送的商品
两个月没有道歉
朋友虽然代为道歉
但也说她没释怀
那并希望我能够理解她的逆龄
因她觉得事业很小没有妨碍我
反而觉得我小心眼
初次遇到要等加害者释怀
看在我朋友的份上没有当面对峙
您会直接爆破妈爱您
這種事情其實雖然不一定
每個人都會遇到像你這麼直接直白的
但你可以了解的是
就是在這個世界上
當大家發現你的生意特別好做
就是你的朋友圈注意到
就在說你是做某種進出口貿易的
然後你超級賺錢
你也都沒有演
你也沒有常思
你就是跟他分享
他不免會思考說
我是不是也要這樣子
就類似說好像我們是做股票的
其實我們身邊很多朋友
都會整天在問股票
我最喜歡的跟單仔是那一種
我有一個朋友說的很好
他說跟單的人就是有耳無嘴
就是你就默默的跟就對了
如果說表情套到你自己知道
有些東西是要停損的
因為不可能沒筆都贏
但是你就是要專心聽
但是遇到不好的事情不要整天抱怨
因為你一旦抱怨下次人家不要跟你講
我覺得這個朋友他真的是
非常專業的跟單仔
他講的很對
因為你整天跑來問我的話
我就不可能再跟你講了
因為我也覺得受到干擾就很煩
有時候我自己也媽的
像居然說這幾個月就也不好做
如果說又要遇到人家那邊整天問說
那個東西怎麼了
媽我怎麼知道怎麼了
你要不要去問川普
還是你要不要去問他媽Dario
我他媽怎麼知道這股價會上會下
你整天跑來問我說這公司怎麼了
媽你為什麼不去問老闆
公司電話Google一查就好
你打電話過去說你找IR
P頭D就好
就你家公司他媽怎麼只會往下
他也想問你問他
他也會想問說
為什麼我們家公司只會往下
是不是你們外面在亂賣
就不要一直問這種很笨很白癡的問題
我也想知道
這種人就很多
反正就是他其實也是
某時候想要你的生活
可是他不想要你的付出
所以他就是只想要用問的
想說我就這樣子take a loan就好
但其實連跟單就是一門藝術
他是不容易的
所以就是說
〔此段辨識失敗，約 40:00 起〕